Germany is in shock after an
anti-semitic attack on a synagogue in
the holiest day of the Jewish calendar
Yom Kippur the Day of Atonement a
heavily armed gunman tried to force his
way into the building in the Eastern
German city of Halle on Wednesday but
was prevented from entering he then shot
and killed a bystander in the street
before killing another person at a
nearby kebab shop well for more let's
bring in DW reporter Kate Brady who's
standing by for us in Halle and our
political correspondent Simon Young is
with us in the studio good day to you
both
Kate what are the latest developments in
this investigation I understand
authorities have been searching houses
there was overnight in the nearby area
of Landsberg there were some searches
done overnight and we heard from
eyewitnesses locals there in Landsberg
that that some officers were going from
house to house and also we've learned
since that at one particular apartment
was searched in isolating and as far as
we know the main suspect who was
arrested yesterday at 27 year old
suspect he actually came from isolating
but we're still waiting to hear from
authorities any more confirmation on
exactly what they found during those
searches and in what way they were
connected to the events here in Halle
and in Landsberg yesterday but the focus
here in hallo today as you can see is
this vigil which is about to take place
behind us here I'm currently stood in
front of the synagogue where that gunman
tried to enter yesterday during those
Yom Kippur services and as you can see
the crowd behind me is growing there's
people from Hallows jewish community and
also other locals from hala coming here
to pay their respects today both to the
two victims yesterday in that shooting
many of them bringing candles and
flowers laying them at the at the door
here just a few meters away from me as
well in respect as well to the Jewish
community here in hi which was attacked
yesterday by that gunman and just behind
this police van there is the door
through which he actually tried to enter
and you can actually see the the gunshot
so that the holes from the bullets where
he tried to enter through that door
yesterday but was fortunately unable to
enter
we're up to around 70 people were
actually attending services at the time
in the synagogue Simon you're following
this investigation as well of course
what more do we know about the attacker
and his motives well twenty
seven-year-old local man who neighbors
say was pretty unremarkable they hadn't
noticed anything about in certainly
nothing suspicious in this sense but
what police say they know about him was
that he had some kind of right-wing
ideological background and there are
some more concrete points because he he
published a kind of manifesto that he
put on the internet about a week ago in
which he said that he had the objective
to kill anti whites and particularly
Jews as he put it and of course this
incident took place on the Jewish holy
day of Yom Kippur and the man also
streamed he live streamed his attack
from a camera mounted on the helmet
online so you know in during that he was
making commentary expressing hatred
against Jews I would also say though
that he seems to have been more
indiscriminate than that when he
couldn't get into the synagogue he
killed a couple of other people who
don't appear to have had any specific
connection and I think this links to
another idea of you know these kind of
attackers is a video game style killing
fantasy of indiscriminate killing this
man also is alleged to have said that he
was happy to kill Muslims and
left-wingers so you know before we say
that it's a purely anti-semitic attack
we should also look at the whole context
and police are obviously investigating
that now well Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has expressed
condolences after yesterday's shooting
here's part of what he said on Twitter
he wrote the terrorist attack against
the Jewish community in Halle on Yom
Kippur is additional testimony that
anti-semitism in Europe is increasing I
send condolences to the families of the
victims and call on the German
authorities to continue taking
determined action against anti-semitism
Simon how serious
is the problem of anti-semitism in
Germany and what our German authorities
doing to address it well it is a serious
problem Jewish groups have been a
warning about growing anti-semitism for
some time and we saw anti-semitic
incidents are 20% for instance last year
with more than a thousand incidents
across Germany the 69 I think violent
attacks so it you know it is a serious
problem of what are the authorities
doing well showing solidarity with the
Jewish community is one thing they're
also talking about stepping up police
action for instance offering them the
opportunity to act more quickly to
identify anti-semitic crimes as a
specific class of crimes rather than
just general racist hatred also giving
courts the opportunity to put people in
jail for longer if they're convicted of
this kind of thing but also groups are
now calling for police protection to be
provided on a routine basis much more to
synagogues it's done in larger cities in
Germany but perhaps it'll have to be
done elsewhere as well now Simon thank
you very much DW political correspondent
Simon Young with me in the studio and
there in hala forest DW reporter Kate
Brady thank you very much to you both